-Right there,
that is five-time Grammy-winning
artist and producer
Robert Glasper in the house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being
here tonight.
With you is Derrick Hodge on
bass and Chris Dave on drums.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Robert, it's always great
to see you
and thank you for
for being here tonight.
I appreciate this.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-I just recently went to see --
Robert has a residency
at the Blue Note
here in New York City
in October.
It's called Robtober.
-Robtober.
-Yeah. And it is unbelievable.
It's one of the best things
I've ever seen.
And every show
is completely different.
-Completely different.
50 sold-out shows.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was the best.
Like, do you know -- Like,
in a roundabout way,
you know, what you're going
to do set-list-wise or no?
-Not really. No.
[ Laughter ]
Because so many people come
and pop up on us
and, you know, it's always
kind of like jam session vibe,
so we kind of know.
But half of it we don't know,
which makes it great, you know?
-Because you'll just start
playing something
and then all of a sudden you're
going into a different thing
and then you're playing
something, then like,
can you just give a taste,
just noodle,
just play just something
just for fun?
[ Up-tempo jazz music plays ]
♪♪
And then you throw in something.
You start throwing in like
weird songs
on top of, like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what I think?
I don't know
if I got you in trouble
or whatever,
because I went
and we had a great time
and I went back
to say what's up
and say hi to you and the band.
And then we went out --
In your dressing room,
out the window,
there's a giant piano.
-Yes.
-Outside the Blue Note.
Like a scaffolding.
-Yeah.
-And we kind of went
and stood on the scaffolding.
-Ohh.
-No, safely.
-Yeah.
-No one knew.
We didn't ask any permission.
We just did it.
-Yeah.
-Anyway, was it last night?
-Sunday night,
the last night of the residency,
this dude, because he couldn't
get in because it was sold out.
So he scaled like Spider-Man.
He sailed --
He scaled the wall.
-Dude has got a video.
He scaled the wall
and then climbed on the piano
and got into his dressing room.
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it was weird.
-The city is crazy, man.
-That's commitment.
-But that means I made it.
-Yeah, yeah, you made it.
Exactly. You made it.
That's exactly right.
I'm happy you're here.
Welcome. Chris,
what is that cymbal, by the way?
I've never seen anything
like that in my lifetime.
-It's called a spiral cymbal
as of now.
-Yeah.
-But the name changes.
-I guess it's a great name
for it.
-And my mom changes the name.
-It's like some kind of
really artsy Christmas tree.
[ Laughter ]
But it's good.
But can you give me, like --
Alright, I'm going to close
my eyes, give me maybe a cymbal
and then give me that cymbal
and I'll see
if I can decide
which one is which.
♪♪
That's not it.
That's it.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ "Jeopardy!" theme plays ]
Alright. It's one of the two.
It's the second or third one.
But I think it's probably
that snaky sound.
That second one
was like a rattlesnake.
[ Cymbal playing ]
It wasn't it?
[ Cymbal plays ]
Oh, that was it.
What was the rattlesnake-y
sound?
That was that one?
Alright. Alright.
We'll be playing around
with you guys all night.
I'm so happy you're here.
And thank you for being here.
Again, Robert Glasper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The best.